THINK WE WILL GET THE OUTCOME
ROBERT IS TALKING ABOUT.
FLORIDA A BATTLEGROUND STATE.
A MUST WIN STATE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT.
DEMOCRATS ARE TURNING OUT AT A
MUCH LOWER RATE THAN REPUBLICANS
IN THE IMPORTANT COUNTY OF MIAMI
DADE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A 9.4% TURNOUT
ADVANTAGE IN MIAMI DADE COUNTY
WHERE BIDEN WILL NEED
A SIGNIFICANT MARGIN OF VICTORY
TO CARRY THE STATE.
HERE WITH MORE FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS.
TELL US ABOUT MIAMI DADE AND
EARLY VOTING.
HOW DO YOU MATCH THIS UP TO 2016
OR YOUR RACE WHEN YOU RAN FOR
GOVERNOR?
>> 4 YEARS AGO THERE WERE
340,000 MORE REGISTERED
DEMOCRATS THAN REPUBLICANS.
NOW IT’S LESS THAN 140,000.
WE ADDED 200,000 REPUBLICAN
REGISTRATIONS.
WE ARE WINNING BY ABOUT 520,000
REPUBLICAN BALLOTS OVER
DEMOCRATS FOR IN OTHER THAN
EARLY VOTING.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO THE MAIL.
BUT WE ARE CLOSING THE EARLY
VOTING AT A MUCH FASTER RATE
THAN IN 2016.
IN MIAMI DADE THE PRESIDENT LOST
IT BY 30 POINTS AND STILL WON
THE STATE.
HE IS NOW IN A SITUATION WITH
THE TURNOUT WE ARE SEEING, HE
MAY BE ABLE TO CUT THAT MARGIN
IN HALF.
A COUNTY AS BIG AS MIAMI DADE
THAT COULD BE A 100,000 VOTE
SWING.
THE CUBAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS
FIRED UP AND THE
VENEZUELA-AMERICANS AND ALL OF
THE HISPANICS THAT UNDERSTAND
THE THREAT THAT MARXISM POSES.
THEY ARE RALLY TO DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S SOMETHING HE HAD TO DO
BETTER AND I DON’T THINK WE
COULD HAVE DONE ANY BETTER AND I
HOPE IT CONTINUES.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THE OTHER
THINGS YOU HEAR ARINGARING -- AR
HEARING FROM FLORIDA AS IT
RELATES TO JOE BIDEN.
DOOM AND GLOOM AND NOT GIVING
ANSWERS ABOUT PACKING THE COURT.
I CAN’T IMAGINE HE WON’T ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS HE WILL
PACK THE COURT.
HE WILL BE BEHOLDEN TO THE LEFT
WING.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING ABOUT HOW
BIDEN HAS HIDDEN THE WHOLE
CAMPAIGN?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S BEEN
ABSOLUTE JOKE.
HE DOESN’T KNOW WHO HE IS
RUNNING AGAINST.
HE SAID HE IS RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE AND THE OTHER DAY TALKED
ABOUT GEORGE W. BUSH.
HIS LOCK DOWN MENTALITY DOESN’T
PLAY WELL IN FLORIDA.
WE HAVE ALL 67 COUNTIES SCHOOLS
OPEN FOR IN PERSON.
5 OF THE 10 BIGGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTRY, AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR ECONOMY IS OPEN.
PEOPLE DON’T WANT TO BE LOCKED
DOWN WANT PARENTS WANT TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL.
THE MESSAGE OF DOOM AND GLOOM IS
NOT WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR.
THE PRESIDENT IS MORE OPTIMISTIC
AND THAT RESONATES MORE.
THE DOOM AND GLOOM ABOUT VOTING
SHIFTED DEMOCRATS TO VOTE BY
MAIL.
GOING INTO ELECTION DAY WE WILL
HAVE 200,000 MORE SUPER VOTERS
WHO WILL TURNOUT.
I THINK THAT MARGIN WILL BE
BIGGER THIS YEAR.
SOME IS FOR THE FEAR MONGERING
BIDEN HAS DONE.
I THINK IT WILL COME BACK TO
BITE HIM.